[Music]
on this Wednesday night five former
World Junior players reportedly told to
surrender to police the first potential
charges in a high-profile sex assault
case that dates back to
2018 Russia accuses Ukraine of killing
its own shooting down a plane carrying
Ukrainian PWS where's the evidence the
possible consequences of controlling the
number of international students in
Canada but it could mean for their
future and for
schools and palacial plans I just said
mine the night taking the Reigns of this
Nova Scotia
Castle global national with Donna
freezen good evening and thanks for
joining us there is news tonight about
allegations of sexual assault involving
former junior hockey players The globan
Mail newspaper is reporting five former
members of can Canada's world junior
hockey team have been told to surrender
to police in London Ontario the
newspaper says it's related to
allegations of a group sexual assault in
a hotel room in London in 2018 the case
was closed without charges in 2019 but
was later reopened McKenzie gray is
following this story for us tonight
McKenzie yeah Don it appears there will
soon be New Revelations on one of the
most high-profile sexual assault
investigations in Canadian history the
glob and mail is reporting five players
from the 2018 Canadian World Junior Team
have been told to surrender to police in
London Ontario to face sexual assault
charges according to two sources Global
News has not been able to independently
verify that information but five players
who were on that team have now taken
leaves of absence from their current
hockey teams there's no confirmation
that the leaves are related to the globe
report but they do include Philadelphia
star goalie Carter Hart whose lawyer
previously told Global News his client
had not engaged in any wrongdoing in the
alleged group sexual assault we are
aware of this morning's press reports on
the various uh um a very serious matter
we will respond appropriately when the
outcomes of the investigations are made
public Cal foot and Michael McLoud of
the New Jersey Devils both took an
indefinite leave of absence on Wednesday
foot who won the Stanley Cup in 2021
with Tampa Bay denied being involved in
the sexual assault through his agent in
2022 former Ottawa Senator Alex foron
left his team in the Swiss league today
while Calgary Flames forward Dylan dub
did the same on Sunday when the team
announced he was leaving to attend to
his mental health Global News reached
out to multiple parties involved
including representatives for all five
players the NHL the NHL players
Association and the lawyers representing
the alleged victims and receive no
responses by deadline the London Police
Service says they have no information to
share at this time but said they
anticipate holding a press conference on
February 5th to discuss the matter the
Ontario Attorney General's office told
Global News it has no files for any of
the five players at the this time news
of the alleged assault first broke in
May 2022 when TSN first reported Hockey
Canada had settled a civil lawsuit with
the complainant from funds paid in part
by youth hockey fees those Revelations
LED London Police to reopen their
investigation Hockey Canada's entire
board and leadership team to quit and
the NHL to start their own investigation
Justice delayed is Justice denied it
also sparked numerous parliamentary
hearings where safe sport Advocates like
Kim Shaw pushed for more accountability
from Canadian sport organizations I feel
really happy that finally sport is
possibly being held to account sport has
long enjoyed this immunity from
criticism from Justice from the law and
I think this is a step in the right
direction the NHL is not commented on
the report from the globin mail but did
have something to say just after the
story was published about the league
expanding Donna welcoming a new bid for
a team in Salt Lake City all right
McKenzie in Ottawa thanks it is now
confirmed six people died in that plane
crash near Fort Smith in the Northwest
Territories it went down shortly after
takeoff near the Alberta border the
tragedy has hit the community hard the
premier says those killed were neighbors
colleagues friends and loved ones Eric
Sorenson looks at what we know about the
crash the aircraft was a jetstream
commuter plane operated by Northwestern
Air lease carrying five passengers and
two crew members only one passenger
survived the impact and was taken to the
Fort Smith Health Center then airlifted
to hospital in Yellow Knife the
passengers were all on route to work at
The diic Diamond Mine The Coroner for
the Northwest Territory says next of kin
have been notified by the RCMP adding
that it's working with local resources
to access the site and begin the
recovery process the Air Force RCMP and
Canadian Rangers were all involved in
the search and rescue local restaurant
owner Anna kiwak says it's like a bad
dream but when tragedy hits your
heart it's hard to describe like Mass
casualties like that just doesn't happen
in forcement like I've never experienced
that before the company that owns diic
Rio Tinto and its workers have been
shaken the chief executive stating we
are feeling numb with the devastating
news that we've lost dear friends and
colleagues we will be working closely
with the authorities to support their
efforts to understand the full facts of
what happened the only Transportation
over vast stretches of Northern Canada
is by air this flight was on route from
Fort Smith to the diic diamond mine
operation Northeast of Yellow Knife a
500 kmet flight the plane took off from
the airport on the western side of Fort
Smith to cross the slave River it's
believed the aircraft ran into trouble
almost immediately and crashed only a
few hundred meters away the diic diamond
mine has been operating in the Northwest
Territories for more than 20 years for
many of its some 12200 employees it is a
Flyin fly out operation workers take
regular flights every month the mayor
and town Council of Fort Smith issued a
statement offering support and prayers
and our condolences to all the families
friends and the community these people
are treasured members of our community
it is devastating news for Northerners
who rely every day on air travel as they
look now to the Transportation safety
board of Canada as it begins its
investigation into what happened Eric
senson Global News Toronto Italian media
is reporting two of the three people
killed in that BC heliskiing crash on
Monday came from well-known family
29-year-old Hiner Jr obero was the son
of the founder of an Italian Sporting
Goods giant 35-year-old Andreas vidman
family owns the Cycling Company Tex
Market the third victim hasn't been
identified four others were injured in
the helicopter crash including Emilio
zero his brother tells Global News when
he was found he was conscious but he has
a broken hip legs and
ribs Russia is accusing Ukraine of
shooting down a military transport plane
which it claims was was carrying 65
Ukrainian prisoners of war that plane
went down in a snowy rural area near the
Ukraine border Ukraine's military says
it has no reliable information about who
was on board and stopped short of
acknowledging it had shot down the plane
though Ukraine's intelligence did accuse
Russia of deliberately jeopardizing the
lives of prisoners of War Crystal ganing
[Music]
Reports a terrorist act that's how
Russia's foreign minister described an
incident in the belgrod region near the
border with Ukraine this debris Russia
claims is what's left of a military
transport plane it says was shot down by
Ukraine Wednesday morning Russia says
all 74 passengers were killed including
65 Ukrainian prisoners of War due to be
exchanged the Ukrainian leadership knew
perfectly well about the upcoming
Exchange they were informed about how
the prisoners would be transported but
the IL 76 aircraft was shot down says
this state Duma official and retired
General video from the village closest
to the crash site shows a plane falling
from the sky and an explosion Ukraine
has not denied shooting it down but in a
statement says there was no information
of the need to ensure the safety of the
airspace because of PS being transported
as they have been in the
past in his nightly address Vladimir
zalinski said it is necessary to
establish all clear facts and called for
an international
investigation this assistant professor
of politics and international relations
says Russia's president and information
Russia disseminates should be viewed
with a high degree of Suspicion he uses
misinformation uh in order to influence
public opinion in the west and in
Ukraine uh to try to get his
way it is a critical time for Ukraine as
attention and funding is waning while
Russian strikes continue Ukraine needs
to be able to stay in the war needs to
be able to get Western weapons and
ammunitions to continue on in the fight
Russia's foreign minister Sergey lavaro
called for an emergency session of the
un Security Council for Ukraine to
explain what happened that session will
be held Thursday Crystal ganing Global
News
London the head of the British military
said today the Western World should
prepare for war with Russia saying it
could be on the scale of the great
conflicts of the 20th century in a
speech in London General Sir Patrick
Sanders said the Russian invasion of
Ukraine is a sign of things to come
Russia's war on Ukraine he says is about
defeating our system and way of life
politically psychologically and
symbolically and how we respond as the
pre-war generation will reverberate
through history Ukrainian bravery he
said is buying time for now he's calling
on the British army to be nearly doubled
in size and for citizens to be trained
so they can be mobilized in the event of
a war in response to his speech the
British government's insisted today
military conscription is not on the
table in the US the United aut Workers
Union has endorsed President Joe Biden
for re-election Biden has build himself
the most labor-friendly leader in US
history and hopes to maintain support
among bluecollar voters in swing States
meanwhile Republican Nikki Haley is
pressing on with her presidential
campaign despite losing to former
president Donald Trump in the New
Hampshire primary yesterday the result
was closer than expected and as Jackson
prco reports she's trying to convince
voters she's the only Republican who can
beat Joe Biden everybody thank you whoa
for a man who won a resounding Victory
Donald Trump sounded a lot like someone
who'd lost and just a little note to
Nikki she's not going to win she's not
going to though he beat Nikki Haley it
was a much closer race than
expected turning Trump's prevote
confidence let her do whatever she wants
it doesn't matter into unhinged anger
let's not have somebody take a victory
when she had a very bad night I have
never seen a winning candidate give a
speech like that after the election but
for somebody who is essentially
presenting himself as a a president in
Exile um who wants to return to the
White House um these aren't necessarily
great
numbers seeing victory in defeat Nikki
Haley will stay a contender this race is
far from over there are dozens of States
left to
go her long-term odds against Trump are
still slim next up Haley's home state of
South Carolina where Trump has already
locked up endorsements I just love you
no that's though Trump still faces
serious criminal and civil trials in the
courts few doubt Republicans will
eventually pick him again Americans May
well do the same in November's election
just like Republicans Democrats are
banking on Donald Trump locking up the
nomination soon in fact President Joe
Biden is already pivoting to focus on
November's expected matchup against
Trump after walking away with than 50%
of the vote here in New Hampshire
Jackson prco Global News Manchester drug
maker Johnson and Johnson has been
ordered to pay Washington State nearly
$150 million over its role in the opioid
crisis more than four years ago the
state sued Johnson and Johnson for
fueling addictions Washington's attorney
general claimed the company deceived
doctors and the public about the
effectiveness of opioids for chronic
pain and the risk of addiction and
British Columbia has reached another
devastating milestone in the talk toxic
drug crisis the province's coroner
service says there were more than 2500
suspected illicit drug deaths in 2023
the highest annual toll ever recorded
the chief coroner says the surging
number of deaths are being driven by
fentanyl a powerful opioid close to
14,000 people in BC have died as a
result of toxic drugs since the province
declared a public health emergency in
April of
2016 a deadly explosion caught on
camera
coming up what ignited this blast in
Mongolia the governor of the Bank of
Canada says the key interest rate will
remain steady at 5% for now inflation is
still too high and underlying
inflationary pressures persist we need
to give these higher interest rates time
to do their work the hold it 5% was
widely predicted it's the fourth time in
a row the Central Bank kept its
Benchmark rate unchanged Tiff mckam
hinted there could be Cuts coming but
wouldn't predict when universities and
colleges in Canada are increasingly
reliant on International students who
often pay up to five times more in
tuition than domestic students now that
the federal government is putting a cap
on foreign students the financial
implications are worrying most
up-to-date stats show Canada took in
nearly 88,000 International students in
2022 a 31% increase from 2021 about 80%
of them went to schools in BC Quebec and
Ontario Ontario getting the bulk of them
colleges and universities say reducing
those numbers will mean a big hit to
their bottom line and as Mike drle
reports the stress is being transferred
to
students when we met Indian student
jatas Kumar vaswani his singular focus
on school was such that he had yet to
buy furniture only if reason why I want
an apartment as a student is that I just
want to sleep money is also an issue
International students like vaswani pay
roughly five times regular tuition rates
which has been critical for many
Canadian schools facing budget
shortfalls but over the past few years
foreign student numbers have grown so
quickly they now outnumber Canadians at
10 of Ontario's 24 publicly funded
colleges Koga and Centennial College uh
two colleges in Southern Ontario
combined over that 16-month period
brought in more International students
and had more uh student visas issued
than Canada's 15 uh research
universities combined do you feel like
you're actually in Canada at
school uh I would say uh no more than
any other school in Canada Koga has
benefited from recruiting
internationally 30,000 or 71% of its
42,000 students come from overseas
leading to a budget surplus last year of
$106 million putting a cap on new
students coming to this country would
essentially turn off that profit
pipeline in an email a Koga spokesperson
said we need to ensure we protect
Ontario's reputation as a leading
destination for international students
and if the rules change it's essential
we get this
right that's true for a number of
reasons the housing marketing Kitchener
which has seen low vacancy rates in
increasingly High rents has become a
serious
problem and the students themselves
worry they're being made into scapegoats
baswani had expected a work permit when
he graduates this spring it's unclear
under the new rules if that will still
happen that's what I have understood
since the beginning when I come here you
have to it's just up to you like so many
other new Canadians all he wants is an
opportunity but it might be out of his
control Mike drite Global News kitner
waterl
Ontario there's some game-changing news
for Canada's top par Olympic athletes
medal winners will now receive financial
rewards just like their Olympic
counterparts the Canadian par Olympic
Committee says the new performance
recognition program will start this
summer at the Paris games athletes who
win gold will get
$20,000 silver medal winners will
receive 15,000 and 10,000 will go to
those who win bronze that's equal to the
amount Olympic athletes received for the
same
achievements criminal charges have now
been laid after that shooting inside
Edmonton city hall yesterday while city
council was
meeting close the doors the gunfire led
to a lock down of City Hall police say
the gunman opened fire randomly and set
off a Molotov cocktail no one was
injured the 28-year-old now faces seven
fire Firearms charges and arson charges
his bail hearing is scheduled for
tomorrow taking to the street still
ahead why thousands in Argentina have
walked off the
[Music]
job this was the scene in mongolia's
capital after a truck carrying 60 tons
of liquefied natural gas crashed and
exploded six people were injured 14
others six people were killed rather 14
others injured and the truck appears to
have crashed into a small car that
caused two explosions the second of
which killed three firefighters who
responded to the scene The Blaze spread
to several buildings including an
apartment and triggered the evacuation
of nearby
[Music]
homes thousands of workers in Argentina
gathered outside the national
legislature to protest big economic and
labor reforms that would slash public
spending the strike was organized by the
country's largest Union and affected
service at airports Banks hospitals and
other public services Argentina is
dealing with triple digit inflation and
massive debt right-leaning president
javar mle was elected last fall on a
campaign of harsh austerity
measures her home is her castle next in
Ontario woman's fairy tale retirement in
Nova
Scotia an Ontario woman has invested a
cool million into some Real Estate in
Nova Scotia and plans to make it her
retirement project it is a big big one
the place is a castle in Cape Breton and
though it's not old or historic its new
owner has big plans for its future Heidi
petruk
explains my name isigo Manya you killed
my father prepare to die in movies like
The Princess Bride castles are places
for swashbuckling sword
fights and in the real world they're
places of Royal pump and Circumstance
but this Castle in Cape Breton Nova
Scotia it seems is the perfect place for
one Ontario woman's retirement my niece
Maggie she had sent me the link to the
castle and when I opened it up I just
said mine just like that I just knew it
that was the right thing to do I
remember the the text was um we need
that castle nearly 10,000 square ft with
10 bedrooms and 18 bathrooms the castle
sits on 1163 Acres complete with
Babbling Brook panoramic views and
private Lake access bill built in 1992
as another Ontario retirees anniversary
gift for his wife Castle Moffett later
became a five-star bed and breakfast and
was sold in 2018 to the Gracie siblings
they listed Castle Gracie in November
and the aptly named Elaine Knight
stepped up with her $1 million offer it
was Castle Moffett Castle Gracie and
then I'm just going with Castle night
but luckily I'm a night before she moves
in though there is work to do the
renovation cost undisclosed and she has
big plans to share the results with
visitors the bulk of it in the
summertime is going to be obviously
Airbnb um and and then maybe one or two
weddings a month just using the river or
sorry the brook as um energy and solar
energy so those ideas are being thrown
around the hope to be ready for
occupancy this summer making Knight's
new home truly her castle IDI pachic
Global News Halifax
a lot of work and that is global
national for this Wednesday I'm Donna FZ
tonight's your candidate is this Snowman
in point CLA Quebec he could be the king
of snowmen we'd love to see your Canada
please email it to viewers global.com
and thanks for watching hope to see you
here again tomorrow
[Music]
bye-bye